je conçois
mais
je vous invite à faire un exercice on va
fermer les yeux et je vais vous demander
de penser à votre métier de l'être dans
passe à moins de moutier de l'air vont y
voir en train de faire quelque chose de
ma merveilleuse dans ce métier là et
dans un ozzy ferment les yeux formant un
suspect aux yeux et pensez à votre
métier de rêve pensez à toutes ces
belles tâches que vous ouvrez exécutées
chaque matin les causes ou les eu le
succès que vous y soyez le soyez joyeux
je pense que c'est merveilleux
on va leur ouvrir les yeux
c'est le pouvoir de visualisation c'est
très intéressant et je vais te parler
qui a passé avec évidemment
ok pas beaucoup mais avec quelques uns
quand même c'est mieux que rien et bien
aussi je pense à l'agriculture et il
faut dire qu'aujourd'hui l'agriculture
est une passion que moi c'est un domaine
que j'ai appris à aimer et ce domaine là
à pouvoir porter au continent en termes
de quantité
mon parcours dans l'agriculture commence
à mon adolescence
lorsque je passe près de jouer dans un
bac à lorient malgré les excellents donc
résultats scolaires et du coup quand
j'ai eu le bac avec une moindre être
juste d'aucuns disent que c'est ça le
vrai mac
j'ai pas eu de bourses d'études et sa
présidence par moments surtout mes
parents avaient rencontré d'énormes
difficultés financer coup j'ai pas pu
commencer l'université à temps ou comme
un promotionnaire et j'ai fait deux
années comme retour pour tina deux
années blanches dans 7 à 10,2 année ça
recommence et universités ça a commencé
dans les études académiques et c'était
difficile pour moi parce que vous savez
quand je quitte le lycée pour aller à
l'université
c'est super chiant voyez dans le privé à
la veste et cravate super beau de voir
de nouvelles motos à cet effet
malheureusement moi j'ai pas eu cette
chance là et puis je vois un
promotionnaire allait bien mais c'est
tout et c'était très difficile avoue qu'
il ya des charges doit même pas
facilement mais je me suis dit vu que
les études ont tourné le dos
vu que je n'en ai plus donc cette
chance-là de pousuivre de même commencer
les études académiques qu'est-ce que je
peux faire en fait pour pouvoir
protéger qu'est ce que je veut initier
pour être autonomes financièrement et
c'est donc avec un ami qui était dans la
même situation qui n'avait pas aussi eu
la chance après son bac
professionnel génie civil devait aussi
d'universités on a décidé de se lancer
dans l'agriculture
après avoir déçu lé se veut dire un
certain besoin
il fallait donc à satisfaire ou certains
problèmes concrets je sais que beaucoup
sar au bout de sa part peut-être
continent période de l'année où y'a pas
d'une le hublot de tout importer dont
nous avons vu son potentiel dans les
sédiments allons-y et donc au début
nous avons appris avec les démentir nous
sommes associés à d'autres aspirants
entrepreneurs et ensuite nous sommes là
ça rentre en compte et on a fait notre
petit bout de chemin dans l'agriculture
notamment dans le maraîchage dans la
production de nos
certains disposant vous pensez de 10
points le mois d'avant
du coup
l'heure est aux questions posées qui j
arrivais à 20 ans au début de la
vingtaine d'être autonome financièrement
de n'avoir besoin de personne
économiquement parle ou au début de la
vie de la reine aimée d'haïti qui a déjà
arrivé tu peux aussi un est généralement
à la vingtaine ont l'air d'avoir déjà la
grosse maison
considère françois que d'autres variétés
de mariée de n'avoir besoin de personne
économiquement parlant et on sait tous
que la réalité est tout autre ça change
de voie et même jusqu'à présent et en a
même qui n'ont pas réalisé un cas de
leurs sept enfants
l'opportunité et moi aussi j'ai rêvé de
ça et ce qui est intéressant c'est que
l'agriculture a permis d'être autonomes
financièrement damas vettel au début de
la vingtaine même si bien sûr ça me fait
mal de le dire j'ai pas encore la pause
ville à la place voiture mais ça va
venir voilà l'essence est question de
l'eau et là j'ai vu la capacité de
l'agriculture ou qu'il a à rendre
financièrement autonome dans les jeux et
il ya vraiment donc du potentiel et donc
je disais que j'ai fait deux années dans
l'incapacité donc de débuter des études
académiques nous voyons aujourd'hui
qu'ea de milliers et des milliers de
jeunes qui sont dans cette situation qui
soit un projet qui sont en situation de
chômage la situation de sous emploi des
diplômés comme des non diplômés et même
plein de jeunes qui n'ont pas eu la
chance vraiment même de faire des études
et de ce que j'ai vu ce que j'ai appris
et de ce que j'ai fait dans
l'agriculture je pense que l'agriculture
est une réelle solution pour contribuer
grandement donc à lausitz problème parce
qu'il ya un très gros potentiel à
exploiter dans ce domaine là encore
l'ancien pas au niveau de la production
la commercialisation et la
transformation et nicole parce que
lorsque nous disons à ridicule
automatiquement les envois production
mais à part que la production la
commercialisation et à la transformation
et tant les jeux qui ne sont pas ou non
ou l'autre peut s'engager dans l'autre
et j'ai vu du jeu produit des céréales
produire des légumes les 25 sortie j'ai
vu deux jeunes gardes les divas j'ai
senti j'ai vu les jeux commercialisés
ces mêmes produits agricoles issus de
sortie de jeu transformé ces produits là
dedans et senti dans l'envoi dans le
contentieux la capacité à l'agriculture
à pouvoir dont autonomiser ces jeunes là
et ça me rappelle donc une anectode a
devancé du domaine qui m'a demandé des
messages selon toi entonne un jeu donc
il avait et un journal occident qui
pensent qu'il est plus simple c'est
beaucoup bu dans cette vision de
domination de se lancer dans la lecture
est donc dit on ici
jeudi par de grandes doses à cette
question je vais essayer d'enlever mon
véhicule et je leur dis j y pense selon
ce que j'ai vécu de cette jeune bout
qu'il avait il a dit effectivement mais
moi je dis ça je dis non parce que je
pense que ce juge pas je ne fume pas je
pense que à vue
quand tu joues accès rodelle ici en tant
que jeu charnière lopin de terre en plus
facilement accès aux dépôts qui n'a que
la balle est entrée par contre face à
ces grands groupes agroalimentaires là
comme là bas et donc plus difficiles à
battre commencez donc dans ce domaine
nicolas et même d'en vivre c'est parce
que même les grands donc un producteur
laval à 100 sorties avec la
mondialisation du tout dans la joie
avant le potentiel et la chance
d'aboutir en tant que jeu de saisi
l'opportunité de ce domaine agricole là
avant que ça devient potentiellement
comme chez eux et donc il a dit oui
cesare ans nous avons avons parlé de ce
sujet un moment et toujours donc amiens
avec cette capacité de l'agriculture
dont à autonomiser les jeunes ce qui m'a
le plus marqué et a retenu mon attention
c'est à trois niveaux trois choses que
le plus soutenu mon attention par une
chose rigueur dans l'agriculture ce que
j'ai vu qu avant de se détendre en moins
tous merci nous davantage concernant ce
chinois d'un demi hectare avec moins
d'un demi million et on a fait des
résultats s'est en sorti la deuxième
chose c'est que le besoin est là les
perdre sinon il est régulièrement
c'est une authentique ou maman losser le
savent y'a pas de cadres c'est importé
il ya des périodes où car maille à
partir ces importés et donc nous on
arrivait
même à 20h un voisin de l'entente
d'ivoire et du ghana et il est même nos
produits car ils disent que ça a un goût
particulier
màj 2 fois pour plaisanter c'est parce
que la terre pour qu'ils aillent vite
voilà déjà un goût particulier
d'ailleurs qui n'avaient par rapport par
exemple nigérien
à
la voit donc le potentiel du potentiel
qu'à cette allure là est la troisième
chose c'est que c'est rentable
nous avec mon amie on arrive donc à vif
et même année investie à tel point qu on
était plus dans l'agriculture pour
l'autonomie financière mais on y est
maintenant lié à rester maintenant pu
viser le business c'est ce qu'elle n'a
en effet pas ce qu au moins six
nouveautés autonomie financière grâce à
ça on a donc à limoux mer cela s'est
passé sans difficulté
tout n'a pas été rose on a fait face à
de nombreuses difficultés et ces
difficultés là était en partie un
premier jugement le fait que la famille
n'était pas pour qu'on se
reconvertissent dans la culture et ça
n'a pas été facile du mans à bergues
départ avant la fin de mois je parlais
pas il ya vraiment du lot boulanger du
climat par serge l'antipathie voilà tout
a changé que dans pas mal du tout et dit
moi j'ai dit à mon papa
après ils ont conclu que porte
la convocation de famille tue depuis le
gage à l'extinction de mon coeur battait
allait se passer lors c'est grossier et
dans n'était pas du tout d'abord et sa
retraite - ne discutait pas à vendre et
c'est que on a eu du mal à passer un bep
s'est produit c'était dû donc à
l'utilisation excessive de pesticides et
engrais chimiques qui sont même
dangereux pour la santé et à des choses
difficulté c'est que en un seul face à
la volatilité des prix la phase deux
fois l'incapacité d'accéder à la tête
des grandes villes on a fait face à
l'incapacité d'avoir de l'âme et de vous
aider vous que les jeux ne sont même
plus qui très intéressés par la culture
à l'art face donc à l'industrie d'avoir
des financements bancaires vu qu'on est
en informer à la surface ont beaucoup
d'obstacles qui peut vraiment des frais
entre époux les genoux se lancer dans ce
domaine mais quand ça ma formation grâce
à la collaboration avec d'autres je m'en
tamponne un casque au procès de
l'évasion
nous avons plus dans franchissait
l'obstacle en revue les jours de danse
et du sculpteur et continuer notre bout
de chemin dans dans ce domaine là et
donc pour ceux ci me fait dire que la
dream team où ils seront dans le futur
est une réelle chance tous ces jeux au
burkina là qui sont en situation de
chômage de son emploi de décrochage
scolaire qui n'ont même pas eu la chance
de débuter les études académiques
l'agriculture a le potentiel de leur
donner un projet professionnel stable
djila l'agriculture de les autonomiser
financière
si ces jeunes gens acceptent d'être la
première mène un projet agricole
si ces jeunes là accepte carrés sur le
terrain où le besoin se sent si mon
combo est du devoir à nous c'est tout
moi on a voulu le
tsg d'avoir avec lui pour nous je vois
ça ne vous est pas foutu de moi dans
cette jeune axel d'avé où il ya le
besoin de me regarder ailleurs que les
grands que parce qu'il ya contre
d'anciennes donc a saisi et je veux des
joueurs pour la boule et
le stade de faire de la couture ou
l'autonomie chance pour maintenant viser
la liberté financière et en plus si
c'est possible on voit le potentiel
est temps qu on dit aujourd'hui que
l'agriculture d'encore et les coûts sont
donc pour les jeux et les titres
d'oussama passerelle est dit difficile
elle édite 500 mais c'est là qu'un le
défi que nous jeunes auront la
possibilité donc de révolutionner ce
domaine là avec de nouvelles méthodes
nouvelles technologies notamment la
culture sous serre la culture hors sol
tout sédières introduction du
motoculteur midi d'actes de nouvelles
technologies de l'éducation comme le
bouddha août de laser ce prêt à
l'inspection a tellement de choses à
faire et donc du coup y'a un peu denses
et la saisie et d'encre tout ceci vous
dit que leur buteur potentiel et que 1
peut apporter je suis diasso ch arrive
l'honneur depuis 2014 et accompagnateur
d'entrepreneurs et tu as fait un
entrepreneur
[Musique]